[Musique]
Bernard Friot, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. On s'excuse par avance
auprès de nos auditeurs pour les
quelques travaux qui s'opèrent en dehors
de notre volonté à l'extérieur de notre
studio. Bernard Friot, bonjour.
Bonjour. Qu'est-ce que est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Je suis retraité de l'université. J'ai
été sociologue pendant une trentaine
d'années sur les questions de sécurité
sociale en particulier
et puis
non économiste pendant une trentaine
d'années pardon et puis sociologue
pendant les les 10 dernières années de
ma carrière.
On vous a convié à venir chez nous pour
un sujet que vous affectionnez qui
s'appelle
le revenu universel.
Ah sûrement pas. Non. Si c'est pour ça
il y a un C'est ça.
C'est le salaire à la qualification
personnelle. Le salaire lié à la
personne. Oui.
Allez-y, on vous écoute. Expliquez-nous.
Pas le revenu. Non.
Pourquoi donc ça ne s'appelle pas le
revenu ? parce qu'un salaire ça
reconnaît qu'on produit alors qu'en
revenu ça reconnaît qu'on a des besoins.
En revenu c'est dans l'ordre du pouvoir
d'achat alors que un salaire c'est la
reconnaissance qu'on contribue à la
production de valeurs économiques. Donc
attribuer un salaire à la personne c'est
postuler que toute personne est en
capacité de produire de la valeur
économique. Alors que dans le
capitalisme, au contraire les personnes
sont suspectées de ne pas être capable
d'en produire en permanence.
On va on va vous passer un petit extrait
pour commencer notre interview histoire
de pimenter tout ça. C'est un extrait
d'une de nos précédentes interview avec
Laurent Alexandre qui s'exprimait, il va
s'exprimer pendant 2 minutes autour du
du salaire universel. Et je vous tourne
l'écran pour que vous puissiez voir.
On peut envoyer
ma grande angoisse c'est que je je
crains que Harari dans Homodéus et
raison. C'est-à-dire qu'on aille vers
des dieux et des inutiles, c'est-à-dire
une aristocratie de l'intelligence et
puis de l'autre côté des gens pour
lequels le monde va devenir trop
compliqué.
Euh
c'est pour moi une grande crainte
politique.
Politique dans quel sens ? Le pouvoir
politique va pas pouvoir gérer la
transition, n'est pas câblé pour, n'est
pas équipé pour ou simplement défend
? Non, je pense que le pouvoir politique
se fout
du fait qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
laisser pour compte.
On voit bien que il n'y a aucune volonté
à
à l'échelle internationale de rénover
l'éducation, de réfléchir à des méthodes
éducatives pour réduire les inégalités
intellectuelles. En réalité, les élites
politiques de droite et de gauche ont
déjà intégré le paradigme de Harari,
c'est-à-dire, on va avoir une un petit
groupe de 10 à 15 % de la population
tout mouillée qui va gérer le monde de
demain et qui va organiser
l'intelligence artificielle. Puis on va
avoir une masse très importante de gens
qui n'auront pas une formation adéquate
et puis qu'on va mettre à la fin au
revenu universel. Et le revenu
universel, c'est une idée extrêmement
conservatrice. C'est pas une idée
bienveillante. Le revenu universel, ça
veut dire nous n'allons pas moderniser
l'école parce que c'est trop compliqué
de moderniser l'école. On va vous [__]
dans un coin. On va vous donner de quoi
vous payez
la téléréalité et du pain et on va
surtout pas essayer de vous rendre
compétitif de l'intelligence
artificielle. Le revenu universel est
l'idée la plus conservatrice que j'ai vu
de toute ma vie. et ça passe pour une
idée de gauche alors que c'est une idée
d'un mépris absolu et total pour les
classes populaires qu'on considère comme
perdu face à l'intelligence artificielle
et dont on considère qu'il est
impossible de les rendre compétitives
par l'éducation, la formation. Le revenu
universel est une idée qui me révulse et
de la et de voir qu'elle est conçue
comme une idée de gauche alors que c'est
une idée d'extrême droite me choque
profondément.
Bernard Friot, qu'est-ce qu'on en pense
?
Oh bah dis l'oxygène de revenu universel
je m'en fiche hein, c'est pas mon
problème. Manifestement le sien c'est
d'être dans les les plus intelligents de
la planète. Euh si c'est ça la distance
hein euh sociale entre les intelligents
et les bêtes, je lui laisse la
responsabilité de ses dire qui sont
qui font partie de l'aristocratie du
savoir tout à fait classique
des tenants de l'intelligence
artificielle et toutes ces bilvcés. On
trouve Est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
en ce moment une upper class qui euh si
je peux me permettre d'être trivial qui
crache sur la la pleb ? Est-ce qu'il y a
une méprise de des hautes classes
sociales face à à la pleb ?
Lui en est une manifestation évidente
mais disons que c'est d'abord la classe
capitaliste, hein, qui est hors la loi
complètement. prenez Arnaud, prenez un
certain nombre de
de personnes qui euh sur la base de de
récupération pour 1 € du textile, je ne
sais trop quelle autre activité
industrielle voué par le capital à la
délocalisation ont constitué des empires
et sont des gens la loi. Oui. Alors
ceux-là sont dans le mépris total.
Certainement. Oui, bien sûr. Oui, oui,
oui. C'est c'est la c'est une classe
sociale précise, hein, qui est la classe
de ceux qui possèdent les moyens de
production.
Bon,
y compris les plateformes collaboratives
et autres formes nouvelles de moyens de
production.
Expliquez-nous alors ce les bons côtés
du salaire universel tel que vous le
concevez.
Le salaire universel, c'est pas moi qui
le conçoit, hein. C'est un long
mouvement depuis plus d'un siècle de
constitution
d'un droit au salaire,
c'est-à-dire d'un droit à être reconnu
comme contributeur et non pas ce que dit
ce que dit ce monsieur là, j'ai pas
l'honneur de connaître
euh
sur
sur la plebe ignorante et cetera. Euh
non, c'est au contraire hein, c'est
postuler que tout le monde est capable
de contribuer au bien commun et de
contribuer à la production en
particulier de valeur économique qui est
le cœur de de d'un fonctionnement d'une
société et le reconnaître dans un droit
politique au salaire, un droit qui est
lié à la personne et non pas un poste de
travail. euh la
ce qui rend possible des euh dès lors
que l'on a un droit un droit au salarié
à la personne, des arbitrages dans ces
temps hein euh
euh où on n'est pas bénévole. Là, vous
vous êtes présenté à moi comme bénévole,
je
ne le pense pas. C'est-à-dire que on est
par ailleurs titulaire d'un salaire
et ce salaire nous permet bah
d'arbitrer nos temps euh pas simplement
pour un travail contraint mais pour des
travaux que nous estimons également
nécessaires
et que nous menons parce que nous sommes
titulaires d'un salaire.
Un peu comme chez Google.
C'est Google. Oui, je connais bien
quelques jeunes Américains qui sont
autorisés à y aller avec leurs chiens,
leur sac de couchage aussi si possible
hein, parce que il s'agit d'être
productif 24h sur 24
euh en tongue et cetera. Oui. Oui. Non
non, tout ça c'est de la rigolade hein.
C'est pas c'est
que vous connaissez
parce que Google a un propriétaire hein.
Ce propriétaire c'est un sacré mafieux
hein.
Comment il s'appelle ? Oh, écoutez, je
m'en fous mais je sais qu'il existe
le donc donnez-nous un cas concret de
mise en place de de ce salaire
universel.
C'est pas un salaire universel hein,
c'est un salaire à la qualification
personnelle. C'est un salaire à la
personne.
Il n'est pas universel au sens où
euh il saurait, je sais pas quoi,
attribuer de la naissance à la mort
puisqu'il reconnaît une contribution à
la production. C'est donc un salaire qui
est plutôt lié à l'acquisition de la
majorité politique, mais à 18 ans par
exemple dans nos pays.
Et euh c'est ces
ces prémisses, bah vous avez bêtant la
situation des fonctionnaires he ou ou
pour prendre la situation controversée
aujourd'hui euh des cheminaux, hein.
C'est-à-dire que le salaire d'un
fonctionnaire ne change pas s'il change
de poste parce que son salaire n'est pas
lié à son poste.
Il n'est pas lié à la mesure de ce qu'il
est en train de faire.
Un salaire de fonctionnaire est lié à ce
qu'on appelle un grade, c'est-à-dire un
attribut de sa personne qui le situe en
tant que personne à un certain niveau de
qualification. La qualification, c'est
la reconnaissance d'une contribution
à la production de valeur économique.
C'est ça la qualification. C'est pas la
certification. Le diplôme, c'est la
reconnaissance qu'on sait je sais pas
quoi moi mamailler
un dispositif électronique. Ça c'est de
la certification, c'est du diplôme. La
qualification c'est un thème qui a été
inventé au cours du 20e siècle à
l'initiative syndicale. C'est pour
reconnaître que l'on produit de la
valeur économique. la bourgeoisie, si
vous prenez Arnaud ou si vous prenez le
gaillard qui a causé des 15 % les plus
malins qui vont maîtriser je sais pas
quoi, pense que il y a eux qui
produisent de la valeur puis que les
autres non. Ou alors sur les formes, ils
vont devenir capables, enfin toutes les
illusions sur la formation tout au long
de la vie pour devenir capable de truc
et cetera et cetera.
la production de valeur économique euh
elle elle est niée euh par la
bourgeoisie capitaliste. Elle nous nie
comme producteur, elle nous reconnaît
comme des êtres de besoins qui avont
droit du pouvoir d'achat, qui avont
droit à à
une un revenu. Mais en revanche, que
nous soyons des producteurs de la valeur
et que nous soyons candidats à maîtriser
la production de la valeur, à maîtriser
l'outil de travail, à maîtriser les
plateformes collaboratives, par exemple,
en expulser
les propriétaires de je sais pas quoi,
de Uber ou de Blablacar ou je ne sais
trop quoi.
Ça c'est totalement nié par la
bourgeoisie et le mouvement des
travailleurs organisés au cours du 20e
siècle, régulièrement dans la CGT en
France. a conquis euh dans le droit de
la fonction publique le fait d'être
reconnu en tant que personne comme
capable de produire de la valeur. Et
c'est ce que Macron qui est l'homme du
capital hein ne supporte pas. C'est pour
ça qu'il veut faire sauter le verrou euh
des chemineaux qui sont dans cette
situation h et puis ensuite faire sauter
le verrou de la fonction publique et
cetera.
Comment ça se passe
ce système ce mode de fonctionnement en
dans un climat de de décroissance ou de
récession économique ?
Ah bah la récession économique, elle a
comme origine la recherche du taux de
profit par l'élimination du travail
vivant, hein. Marx a très bien montré ça
dans l'analyse qu'il fait du capital.
Euh la recherche du taux de profit se
fait en multipliant la machine au
détriment du travail vivant. Mais euh ça
fait que le capital que l'on avance pour
produire quelque chose inclut de plus en
plus de travail morts dans la machine et
de moins en moins de travail vivant qui
lui est supporte de la valeur nouvelle.
Et donc le taux de profit qui est le
rapport entre la valeur nouvelle créée
et le capital avancé a tendance à
diminuer. Et euh la façon dont le
capital se
dépêtre de cela, c'est la fuite en avant
dans le capital fix fictif, c'est-à-dire
dans les aventures financières,
dans la déconnexion vis-à-vis de
l'économie réelle. Oui, c'est ça. Par la
le fait de de susciter de la demande par
de la dette, enfin bref, de la folie.
Euh et précisément le le le salaire à la
qualification personnelle, le fait que
nous devenions les seuls à être reconnus
en tant que travailleur comme producteur
de la valeur nous pose au contraire
comme légitime à revendiquer la
propriété de l'outil de travail et donc
à sortir notre monde de la de la folie
dans laquelle le capitalisme le conduit.
Et par rapport à la décroissance sur
l'épuisement des ressources, comment ça
se passe si tout le monde a le droit à
cette qualification ? Quand vous avez
une démographie en accélération, comment
ça se passe ? Est-ce que est-ce que ce
système-là
euh est applicable par exemple au taux
de natalité de l'Afrique ?
La démographie en accélération, c'est
euh la la situation euh
qui se dépasse dans tous les pays, hein.
Euh ce qu'on appelle
sauf dans 10 dans 10 pays européens.
Ouais. Mais enfin ce qu'on appelle la
transition démographique, c'est-à-dire
que lorsque euh le le l'espérance de vie
augmente, le taux de natalité diminue.
Il y a il y a un lien entre augmentation
de l'espérance de vie et baisse du taux
de natalité. Donc les pays dans lequels
l'espérance de vie augmente peu peuvent
avoir effectivement euh des formes
d'explosion démographique. Mais tout ça
sur le long terme n'a pas n'a pas n'a
pas d'importance.
Euh la décroissance, elle est pas
nécessaire
euh
pour des raisons enfin ou alors j'ai pas
mal j'ai mal compris le lien que vous
faites entre décroissance et explosion
démographique. Vous dites que il faut de
la décroissance mais qu'il y a un
obstacle démographique j'ai pas dit
qu'il fallait quoi que ce soit. Je vous
pose la question. Alors on va reformuler
différemment la la question. La
décroissance ça vous fait penser à quoi
?
La décroissance, ça me fait penser
au fait de
d'en finir
avec des consommations absolument
inutiles, d'en finir avec des
productions
qui pour des raisons de rentabilité du
capital se font dans un dans une
division internationale du travail
absurde où des matières premières font
des milliers, des dizaines, des
centaines de milliers de kilomètres
alors que on peut produire de façon
beaucoup plus local. Euh c'est toute une
série de grands projets inutiles qui ne
sont mis en place que pour tenter de
continuer à à fournir de la matière à
plusvalue à du capital qui a un taux de
profit en régression.
C'est euh le fait de d'entretenir pour
30000 € par jour des centaines de de
policiers dans la vallée de La Roya pour
faire mourir de froid euh tout en
criminalisant
euh les passeurs
qui essayent, je parle, on les appelle
passeurs par dérision du côté de la
police ou du côté de Sioti ou du côté du
préfet, mais tous ceux qui soutiennent
ces migrants
pris dans les froids actuel
euh il y a assurément la moitié de ce
que nous faisons qui peut être qui
pourrait ne pas être produit, ça c'est
certain. En revanche
et là je peux acquier ce que disait
l'intervenant auparavant,
en revanche, nous avons des tas de
besoins en particulier en matière
d'éducation qui sont totalement non
satisfaits.
Est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
connaissez le rapport Midose ? le le le
rapport Oui oui oui oui oui oui oui oui
oui oui oui oui enfin vous parlez du
club de Rome vous voulez parler de de
si vous voulez le le problème
de de ce genre de proposition à l'époque
où elles sont formulées
c'est qu'elles ne mettent pas en cause
le capitalisme. Elle met en cause la
technique, le je sais pas quoi, enfin
des machins comme ça, mais pas
véritablement les raisons qui font que
nous allons
dans le mur du point de vue écologique,
hein, parce que la ce qui mobilise la
production aujourd'hui, c'est la mise en
valeur du capital. Tant que c'est ça qui
mobilise la production,
nous nous aurons des problèmes que le
rappeur MOS ne ne
désigne pas comme tel parce que c'est
plutôt une opération interne au capital
qui essaie de sauver la mise
par du capitalisme vert et cetera et
cetera. Il faut inclure dans notre PIB
le le l'indice du bien-être comme au
bout de temps.
Non, je je je pense que le PIB il doit
mesurer la valeur économique, mais il
faut faire bouger en revanche ce qu'on
appelle valeur économique, ça c'est
certain. Euh si on appelle valeur
économique encore une fois le fait
d'entretenir des flics pour criminaliser
les salariés d'Air France parce que deux
cadres le jour où on annonce des
licenciements voir le leur chemise
arrachée et que ça les traumatise à vie
et que et cetera et cetera, euh
finissons-en avec cette définition de la
valeur si vous voulez bien.
Les politiques, ils vous ils vous
écoutent, euh ils vous entendent, euh
ils s'en battent un peu les hein ou ils
font quoi ? Ils vous ignorent, ils font
quoi on leur parle. Mis à part Benoît
Amont euh le grand c'est quoi les
politiques ? C'est ça la question.
Oui, c'est quoi ? Je vous voilà
parce que euh si c'est la classe
politique, c'est pas vraiment
intéressant, on le voit bien maintenant,
y compris dans la relève par la digte
société civile que fait la République en
marche. Tout ça, tout ça n'est pas
extrêmement intéressant.
C'est votre copain Macron ? Non.
J'ai écrit un petit bouquin qui se vend
d'ailleurs pas mal qui s'appelle Vaincre
Macron. Euh
et effectivement, c'est pas mon copain.
Oui.
Mais si par si comme si le sujet
politique c'est vous et moi,
je me rends compte que
des propositions dès lors qu'on on fait
bien la distinction entre revenu
universel et salaire à la personne hein
qui qui peuvent faire l'objet de
confusion et et le fait que vous m'ayez
mis dans les pattes le truc sur le
revenu universel montre que peut-être
vous faites la confusion au départ dès
lors que je
suisé
dès lors que la la confusion est levée,
hein. Euh moi ce qui m'intéresse, c'est
que précisément euh je vais être tout à
l'heure dans un amphi à Nentaire, je
serai demain avec des euh des des élus
municipaux
dans une ville
de de la banlieue parisienne.
Après-demain, c'est les amis du monde
diplomatique qui qui qui m'invitent à à
Beson en fait et cetera.
Là, je m'aperçois que
ceux qui doivent devenir les sujets
politiques, les les les maîtres de la
politique, ceux-là sont intéressés par
ce que je raconte. Oui. Oui, tout à
fait.
les acteurs locaux, les acteurs de
terrain,
des acteurs de terrain, je pense je sais
pas quoi, des cafés dans le plateau des
1000 vaches ou des syndicalistes
de Talè
qui ont des contrepropositions pour que
notre industrie ne soit pas une
industrie de vente d'armes mais une
industrie éventuellement de défense
nationale parce qu'il en faut une mais
certainement pas de vente d'armes et
cetera. Ça se dire qu'il y a des il y a
il y a il y a une multiplicité
de militants dans ce pays à tout niveau
qui et auquel je peux parce que je les
rencontre souvent rendre hommage.
C'est magnifique. Euh ce mécanisme de de
salaire universel, est-ce qu'il est
compatible dans un monde libéral
mondialisé où les entreprises peuvent se
délocaliser en moins de 24 heures.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On leur impose le
pot commun, la cotisation au pots commun
et on les nationalise. On en fait quoi ?
On les laisse partir
les deux. Les deux. Les deux. Les deux.
C'est-à-dire que évidemment là on le
voit vraiment depuis maintenant 40 ans,
la mondialisation du capital fait que
la bourgeoisie capitaliste n'a plus
besoin de négocier sur un territoire
comme la France par exemple.
Elle a plus rien à négocier. Vous êtes
pas content, je m'en vais. hein, elle a
les moyens de se mettre en valeur euh
sur des formes de plus en plus euh
déconnecté d'une logique territoriale.
Donc euh la réponse à cela, elle est
elle est absolument évidente, c'est que
nous soyons propriétaires de l'outil
physique parce que y compris le prétendu
immatériel, il est extrêmement physique.
On a augmenté de 10 % euh notre
consommation d'électricité uniquement
pour les les portables et autres
activités. dite de l'immatériel.
Donc il faut qu'on soit propriétaire de
l'outil. Ça c'est clair.
On on nationalise.
Alors le mot le mot peut prêter à
confusion s'il est confondu avec
étatisation parce que souvent la
nationalisation a été une étatisation
sans véritable pouvoir des travailleurs
ce qui était pas le cas de la solisation
que les communistes font de l'EDF GDF en
46. Par exemple, Marcel Paul crée un
statut de l'énergéticien et gazier qui a
des pouvoirs économiques. Les
travailleurs ont du pouvoir. C'est pas
simplement une étatisation. Les
communistes ont veillé à ce que nous
ayons un dispositif dans lequel les
travailleurs ont du pouvoir. Mais euh si
vous prenez les les nationalisations de
81 par exemple euh
des banques et autres, c'est assez
fictif. Il y a très peu de pouvoir pour
les travailleurs. Donc la la la
propriété de l'outil de travail n'a de
sens que si c'est nous qui décidons,
bien sûr. Alors ensuite,
nationalisation, ça évque ça évoque une
échelle à l'échelle de la nation, ce qui
est juste pour la SNCF, pour des
industries de réseau, il faut une
échelle nationale bien sûr ou
internationale, mais enfin c'est pas une
échelle locale qui est pertinente. En
revanche, on va pas
faire rentrer une boulangerie de
quartier dans un dispositif sur le de
mariage de territoire national. On est
dans une logique beaucoup plus locale et
donc la propriété doit être le fait
d'une collectivité extrêmement locale.
Bien sûr.
Comment ça se passe avec les Free Riders
? Vous comprenez mon expression ? Free
Rider ? Euh non, pas vraiment parce
qu'encore une fois, comme je vous l'ai
dit, euh je connais pas la chaîne dans
laquelle vous me faites intervenir. Je
suis pas du tout un homme de l'internet,
j'ai pas de téléphone. Je vais bientôt
me retrouver en tôle avec coupa, mais
euh euh je ne participe pas à tout cela
et donc j'en ai conscience, j'ai
conscience de son importance, mais du
coup, je sais pas ce que c'est qu'un
free rider,
celui qui
ou un cavalier libre, mais je sais pas,
c'est ça. Voilà, un cavalier un cavalier
libre. celui qui touche sa son salaire
qui ne fait rien avec qui comp
Bon, il me dérange beaucoup moins
qu'Arnaud hein qui qui touche beaucoup
plus qu'un salaire et qui et qui fait
hélas beaucoup de merde donc ça ça me
dérange pas très franchement.
On en fait quoi s'il y en a beaucoup ?
Pourquoi il y en aurait-il beaucoup dès
lors que nous serions les
Ça fait 40 ans qu'on les démotive.
Ça fait 40 ans qu' des motifs qui qui
ont et donc
on va dire que ce système qui bro
l'humain autour du travail démotive les
gens pour travailler. Alors démotive pas
vous qui êtes là et je pense que vous
êtes en train de travailler. Donc euh
c'est pas
travaillez pas là. C'est les vacances
pour nous. Vous dit on va passer une
petite après-midi avec ça la question
mais c'est ça la question c'est quoi
travail en ce moment je travaille hm
euh et je suis payé. Euh j'ai une
pension de retraite euh
qui est de combien ?
Qui est à vie ? Qui est de 4300 € par
mois.
Nette.
Nette. Oui.
Et
la la
c'est pour ça que je je je suis un chaud
partisan, hein, du fait que chacun soit
titulaire d'un salaire qui fait que en
permanence, il a la liberté
d'affecter son temps aux productions
qu'il estime pas tout seul d'ailleurs
hein, que parce que dans tout travail il
y a de la contrainte, il y a des
contraintes de de du de l'outil, il a
des contraintes de de du temps, enfin et
cetera. C'est tout à fait normal, hein,
des contraintes de partenariat et
cetera, mais que il il
utilise son temps dans la dans la
liberté de sa
de ses choix, de sa créativité. C'est
extrêmement décisif.
Euh et ça, encore une fois, ça suppose
que l'on soit propriétaire de l'outil.
Ça, moi je ne vois pas d'autres
conditions
absolument indispensable. L'autre
condition, il y en a deux à mon avis, si
j'en vois une deè bien sûr, c'est le
fait queon ait l'horizon long d'un
salaire lié à la personne, qu'on soit
pas dans l'inquiétude de ce qu'on
gagnera demain, parce que ça ça n'est
pas l'inquiétude de très mauvaise
conseillère.
Oui, le stress, on va dire, néfaste la
créativité.
Comment on finance tout ça pour avoir un
un prisme de lecture long ? une
confiance sur le moyen terme alors qu'on
est dans un système à l'heure actuelle
overstetch comme ils disent là-haut,
hypertendu,
que ce soit sur des facteurs
économiques, écologiques, géopolitiques.
Bah, écoutez, nous nous produisons alors
euh pour le meilleur et pour le pire
encore une fois, parce que dans cette
production-là, il y a beaucoup de merde
hein, mais nous produisons pour 1400
milliards euh d'euros euh de ce qu'on
appelle la production marchande, hein.
Le PIB, c'est un peu plus de 2000
milliards d'euros dont 1400 milliards de
production marchande. La monnaie qu'on
peut distribuer dans un pays, c'est
celui celle qui correspond à cette
production marchande. Donc, on peut
distribuer 1400 milliards.
Nous sommes 50 millions de plus de
résidents qui ont plus de 18 ans, divisé
1400 par 50 millions. Voyez, ça donne
2800 28000 € par an.
2300 € en moyenne. En moyenne, nous
pouvons assurer 2300 € de salaire par
personne et par an. Alors, je dis une
moyenne parce que je suis favorable à
hiérarchie des salaires.
Expliquez-nous ça.
Jusqu'à 6000 € c'est ça ? Oui. Euh oui.
Euh pourquoi ? Parce que j'ai fait une
multiplication par 4 d'une d'un premier
salaire de 15, hein. Je suis parti de la
proposition de la CGT euh qui me paraît
tout à fait euh
réaliste de quatre niveaux de
qualification.
Euh mais donc j'en conclus qu'il faut un
rapport d'un à 4 dans les salaires. Pas
au-delà pas au-delà c'est c'est tout à
fait excessif. D'ailleurs, je ne tiens
pas ça pour une vérité d'Évangile, hein.
peut ça peut se réduire si
collectivement nous décidons de réduire
enf et cetera ça je n'ai pas de je pense
que on peut partir
d'un rapport de 1 à 4 et comme en
général ce qui a préconisé ces 1500 €
net comme premier niveau de
qualification et et qu'à 18 ans donc
tout le monde aurait le premier niveau
de qualification et 1800 € 1500 € net
euh multiplié par 4 maximum de 6000.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous répondez à vos
détracteurs qui disent voilà Bernard
Friot et ses propositions incantatoires
?
C'est pas du wishful thinking.
Écoutez, si vous pouvez éviter un tout
petit peu l'anglais Samir si voulez en
tout cas que je vous comprenne.
C'est pas c'est pas de la branlette
intellectuelle.
Je suis un historien depuis depuis
maintenant euh 45 ans ou davantage
depuis les années 70. Je me fais
l'avoquer du diable, hein. Mais vous
avez raison, on est là pour ça. Euh
je je je j'observe ce qui a été
construit et donc ma proposition, encore
une fois, c'est pas du tout une idée que
je sortirai comme ça de mon chapeau.
C'est qu'est-ce que nous pouvons tirer
du déjà là, de l'existant ? Et donc,
additionnons tous ceux qui pour le
moment correspondent peu ou prou au fait
que le salaire, c'est un attribut de
leur personne et non pas d'un poste et
qui du coup un salaire
qui les confirme en permanence comme
digne de produire de la valeur
économique.
Ce qui est très important parce que le
capitalisme en permanence au contraire,
il nous il nous suspecte d'indignité.
D'ailleurs, l'école nous forme ça avec
les notes. Moi, j'ai toujours été bon
élève, je me suis pas rendu compte mais
maintenant j'étais long avant de me
rendre compte que quelqu'un qui s'est
tapé un 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 de faveur
et cetera,
pendant 15 ans, il a complètement
intériorisé qu'il est incapable. Et donc
c'est c'est c'est dramatique
et et donc le le système des notes doit
sauter évidemment
si on veut une une école qui soit une
école de la coresponsabilité he c'est
nous qui travaillons, c'est nous qui
devons décider, c'est nous qui devons
être propriétaires, c'est nous qui
devons être coresponsables.
Euh sauf que j'ai oublié la votre
question dans l'intervalle mais vous
aussi. qu'on va passer à autre chose.
La compatibilité avec l'Euro, c'est
compatible avec l'Euro. On va revenir à
l'autre question, vous inquiétez pas.
Alors, moi, j'ai été un un un adversaire
acharné de la monnaie unique qui est
absolument aberrant. D'ailleurs, tout le
monde n'a pas été fou pour passer à
l'euro, hein. Les Anglais, les Suédois
et cetera sont restés avec leur monnaie.
Et puis l'euro comme monnaie commune,
hein. Que l'euro soit une monnaie
commune, ça y en faut une monnaie
commune. Mais que ce soit la monnaie
unique, c'est totalement fou. Donc ça
n'est pas compatible bien sûr hein, mais
ça n'est pas compatible avec l'Union
européenne en général qui a été
construite comme une espèce de prison
des peuples. Et donc c'est
si nous libérons
du capital pour produire, si nous
devenons propriétaires de nos outils,
forcément ne serons pas eurocompatibles.
Mais mais d'un point de vue politique,
mon souci c'est pas de construire un nom
à l'euro. Ça c'est ça ça ne mène à rien.
Mon souci, c'est de construire un oui à
quelque chose qui mobilisera de sorte
que nous sortirons de l'euro. Mais
la c'est ce oui qu'il faut construire
là. Si vous prenez euh la la
majorité euh de nos de nos concitoyens,
il s'estiment indign de diriger les
entreprises pour le moment. Euh ils
pensent qu'ils en sont pas capables. Il
faut que il y a beaucoup attendent que
quelqu'un leur donne du travail. Enfin,
on est on a été tellement socialisé hein
dans cette indité.
Bah oui, infantilisé. Mais totalement à
la fois irresponsabilisé puisque on on
ne décide pas euh de l'essentiel euh de
l'investissement, de ce qu'on va
produire, où, comment, avec qui et
cetera, dans quel dans quel négociation
internationale et cetera. C'est pas nous
qui en décidons, c'est la bourgeoisie
qui dessine à notre place. Et en même
temps qu'on est infantilisé sur
l'essentiel, on est en permanence
sanctionné. On est sanctionné par du
chômage, sanctionné par un entretien
avec le N +1 qui nous dit "C'est sûr que
tu es bien à ta place là, tuis pas faire
une petite formation ?" Enfin tout le
temps cette
c'est c'est terrible. C'est terrible.
On saute du Cocalan.
Ouais.
Vous êtes pour ou contre l'euthanasie
chez les vieux ?
Ah, je
euh
je à mon avis compte parce qu'on sait
pas très bien quand est-ce que ça
s'arrête ce genre d'affair.
Euh
[Musique]
je sais pas, j'ai j'ai j'ai discuté avec
une amie qui est accompagné en Belgique
que c'est pas aussi en Belgique
euh
le le le la mort donnée à quelqu'un qui
était pas si âgé que ça mais qui
estimait que il fallait en finir.
Je sais pas, j'arrive pas j'arrive pas à
quier à cette logique.
Vous
vous êtes penché un peu plus sur le
sujet ? Non
non
du tout.
Revenons à N moutons.
Est-ce que vous avez une lecture sur ce
qui est en train de se passer avec cette
fameuse crise financière de 2008 qui est
censée être terminée ? Est-ce que à vos
yeux ça revient à Grand Galot ? On est
peut-être à l'inverse sauvé.
On en est où là au niveau du système
financier ? Ah non non, enfin bon, je
suis pas un spécialiste hein. Moi je
suis un spécialiste de l'économie du
travail, de la sociologie du travail. Ça
fait
économiste pendant 30 ans ? Non.
Oui, mais économiste du travail. Euh
alors un peu généraliste parce qu'il
fallait enseigner la monnaie euh et
cetera, tout ça évidemment. Mais donc
euh donc je suis pas totalement culte,
mais enfin, il ferait quand même pas me
pousser trop longtemps dans mes
retranchements.
Ah essayer toujours. Oui, vous verrez,
ça pourrait être assez pitoyable. le le
euh
le
voyez, j'ai déjà oublié votre truc. Euh
le système le système financier.
Oui. Oui. Alors bah la crise de 2007 et
de 2008 est tout à fait symptomatique
pour moi.
Ça vient d'où ?
J'ai propose une analyse très globale au
départ, hein. Nous avons euh une forme
de recherche de rentabilité dans le
capital qui est totalement absurde
puisqu'il s'agit d'éliminer le travail
vivant alors que seul le travail vivant
est source de valeur. De l'éliminer euh
parce que on attend de du fait qu'il
s'appuie sur un outil,
on attend qu'il soit plus productif, ce
qui est vrai à l'échelle purement
individuelle. Sauf que le coût de cet
outil étant de plus en plus considérable
relativement au travail vivant qui est
mobilisé, le taux de profit se réduit
même si le taux de plus-value lui
augmente. Le taux de profit se réduit et
vous avez donc une recherche est perdue
de sortir de cette réduction de taux de
profit. La façon la plus classique,
c'est la guerrein. On détruit l'appareil
productif du coup
avec un peu d'inflation. commence euh il
y a des formes de guerre
dite pacifique qui consistent à détruire
l'outil, à le délocaliser en fait et
cetera et cetera et cetera. Bon
et puis il y a une autre forme
qui est de s'emparer de part nouvell
d'activité pour qu'elle devienne source
de profit. C'est par exemple le projet
Macron pour la SNCF,
le projet Macron pour
pour toutes les privatisations qu'il
veut accélérer dans notre pays, mais il
est pas le premier à avoir privatisé, he
bien sûr. Euh
c'est
l'autre l'autre solution, c'est donc
celle qui a été choisie à partir des
années 80 90, c'est effectivement
de l'endettement, de soutenir la demande
par de l'endettement
jusqu'au jour où ça pète. Bon, comme on
a continué, ça pètera à nouveau, bien
sûr. Oui, ça c'est évident. On n'est pas
du tout sorti de la crise, pas du tout,
au contraire.
Est-ce que vous avez intégré le
paramètre énergétique dans votre lecture
du début de la crise de 2007-2008 ?
Est-ce que vous avez regardé
l'antériorité des prix du baril par
exemple quand il est monté à 147 90 ?
Est-ce que vous pensez pas que c'est
plutôt une crise énergétique
qu'une crise financière à proprement
parler ?
Je sais pas.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me décrire ce
qu'est une fonction exponentielle ?
Non, je sais que ça augmente de plus en
plus vite, mais vous l' décrire au-delà
de ce de
ce discours très général.
Question d'internet. Qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui empêche la mise en place
du salaire universel pour
l'interrogation ?
Qu'est-ce qui empêche la mise en place
du salaire à la qualification
personnelle ?
Évidemment le la classe dirigeante la
classe dirigeante
et là j'acquaisserai à l'intervenant du
que vous avez mobilisé au départ. La
classe dirigeante, elle a tout intérêt
à distribuer 800 balles à tout le monde
parce qu'avec ces 800 balles, les
personnes vont travailler de faitin. On
le voit bien très bien les les jeunes.
Moi, j'ai formé beaucoup de jeunes dans
40 ans de
Vous êtes fier de de la formation que
vous avez ?
Ah oui, très fier. Oui, bien sûr. Oui.
Vous avez pas formé des futurs chômeurs
? J'ai formé des gens dont le salaire a
diminué de moitié
parce que ils ont été victimes des
mesures jeunes, hein, comme vous l'a été
vous-même à mon avis, la plupart de ceux
qui sont ici. Euh depuis 77, on a
inventé les mesures jeunes, hein.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le service civique,
c'est
ça a été les emplois jeunes, ça a été le
contratemp solidarité, ça a été les
tucs, les SIVP, enfin tout ça.
au nom d'un mensonge d'État qui disait
que un jeune sur qu était au chômage et
que donc face à ce désastre mieux valer
des petits boulots que rien du tout.
C'est un mensonge d'État. Jamais un
jeune sur 4 n'a été au chômage. Le taux
de chômage c'est 25 % chez 25 ans. Ça
veut pas dire que je ne suis au chômage.
Un taux de chômage au numérateur vous
avez les chômeurs mais au dénominateur
vous avez les actifs uniquement. Ça veut
dire que un jeune actif sur 4 est au
chômage, mais comme 70 % des jeunes sont
à l'école, euh ça n'est que le quart de
de 30 % qui qui est au chômage, 7,5 %,
ce qui est la le pourcentage moyen dans
toutes les tranches d'âge. Donc sur la
base de ce mensonge d'État, on a
complètement disqualifié la jeunesse. On
ne l'a plus du tout embauché à la
qualification. Je ne connais
pratiquement plus de jeunes diplômés
aujourd'hui qui s'embauchaient à la
qualification, sauf dans la fonction
publique. Ils sont embauchés pour un
contrat de mission, c'estd d'objectif,
un contrat de chantier, un contrat de
projet, un machin qui est le retour au
salaire à la tâche quand ils sont payés,
hein, parce qu'on va quand même pas
payer en plus ces jeunes. Ils sont en
service civique, on fait appel
à l'intérêt du boulot qu'ils font. Ils
sont bénévoles. Le travail gratuit dans
l'audiovisuel est une plie absolue et
cetera et cetera.
Il y a donc j'ai assisté à ça, non pas
parce que je formais de moins moins bien
ces jeunes hein, mais parce que ils ont
été victimisés, hein. Quand on veut
casser la gueule à une catégorie
sociale, on la victimise d'abord. On a
dit les pauvres jeunes et les pauvres
jeunes qui ont bien du mal.
C'est dur avec les pauvres vieux là si
en ce moment non. Alors les pauvres
vieux justement pour le moment il y a
pas de pauvres vieux. C'est pour ça
qu'on veut en créer hein parce que c'est
emmerdant qu' a pas de pauvre vieux qui
est bien du mal.
Euh les vieux sont considérés comme
trois riches dans nos pays.
Chiant.
Alors chiant
je connais beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
chiants. Macron est jeune ça n'empêche
pas d'être extrêmement chiant. Donc
c'est pas c'est pas l'âge qui fait qui
fait l'emmerdement, j'ai pas
l'impression. En tout cas euh
vous des perches
que je saisis avec allégresse vous
et amour.
Oui bien sûr.
Bon allez arrêtons des conneries.
Comment remplir les emplois peu
envisageables peu enviables mais
nécessaires ?
Alors les emplois peu enviables mais
nécessaires.
Est-ce qu'il y en a tant que ça ?
Je sais pas. Vous vous voyez explorer
parce que moi les sociologues de de du
travail ont font des tas d'enquêtes qui
montrent que prenons les les les
ripeurs, les éboueurs,
ce sont des gens qui sont très fiers de
leur travail. Ils ont une parfaite
conscience que si ils étaient pas là,
notre espérance de vie n'y vait plus
vite que si on fermait les hôpitaux.
Donc la la valeur d'usage, ce qu'on
appelle la valeur d'usage, l'utilité
sociale de ce qu'ils font, ils en ont
une parfaite conscience. ce qu'il
n'aiment pas, c'est leur emploi, c'est
les horaires, c'est le salaire, c'est
euh et cetera et cetera. Mais euh s'ils
avaient un salaire à vie, euh s'ils
opéraient de jours comme tout le monde
euh et non pas de nuit, si ceci cela,
euh si nos rues n'étaient pas encombrées
par les bagnoles et donc qui pouvaient
faire le le leur travail sans problème,
euh nous trouverions des riapers. Alors
maintenant à supposer qu'on en trouve
pas ou alors ce soit des travaux de nuit
par exemple hein euh pour des industrie
de process, on peut pas se passer alors
je parle pas du travail de nuit qui
consiste à vendre des parfums sur les
Champsélysées à minuit. Ça c'est c'est
de la merde dont on va se passer
évidemment mais le le euh le le
travail à l'hôpital de nuit, il est
absolument indispensable
dans certaines industries de process en
chimie et autres. Si on arrête le
processus tout foire, donc il y a bien
du travail de nuit qui est
indispensable. Or, c'est un travail qui
est extrêmement dangereux pour la santé.
Euh donc, on comprend que il faille
trouver des supports qui encouragent à
ce travail-là. Euh et la c'est pour ça
que je suis pour la hiérarchie des
salaires, ce qui permettra de faire
progresser plus vite en qualification
celles et ceux qui accepteraient d'être
de travailler de nuit pendant 5 ans de
leur vie. Peut-être pas trop hein, faut
pas faut pas exagérer. Mais mettons 5
ans de leur vie, il monteraiit plus vite
en qualification.
Vous avez un avis sur les cryptoonnaies
?
Non,
pas du tout.
Non, pas du tout. Je connais pas bien le
Bitcoin, tout ça. Je connais pas
le Bitcoin. Non,
non, non, non. Faut pas me poser de
questions là-dessus. J'ai pas de d'avis
sur tout, loin de là. Et j'en ai même de
moins en moins sur beaucoup de choses
parce que c'est ça le
c'est la vieillerie. Euh non, c'est un
chercheur. Le chercheur euh il sait le
coût d'entrée des choses et donc il ne
s'aventure pas sur les terrains pour
lesquel il n'a pas eu ce coup d'entrée.
Est-ce que vous avez de l'espoir sur le
déroulement de de votre scénario de de
salaire universel ou de salaire adossé à
la qualification ? Ah oui ouioui bien
sûr bien sûr hein. Je m'aperçois euh
vraiment
en permanence
parce que c'est c'est c'est tout le
problème de la contradiction dans le
capitalisme hein. Alors certes en
faisant chuter de moitié le salaire d'
aujourd'hui un jeune a 25 ans, il gagne
deux x et demi de moins que ce qu'il
aurait gagné à la fin des années 60.
deux fois et demi de moins. Hm. Il y a
eu un effondrement du salaire
d'embauche. Mais cet effondrement du
salaire d'embauche euh qui a eu du coup
des effets aussi à la baisse sur la
totalité des salaires, c'était le but
recherché. Bien sûr, cet effondrement du
salaire d'embauche a un effet euh tout à
fait euh peut-être inattendu pour ceux
qui l'ont promu. Euh euh c'est que
beaucoup de jeunes ne vont plus sur le
marché du travail.
Beaucoup de jeunes euh
pour des raisons écologiques également
ne veulent pas produire de merde pour le
capital, y compris de la merde sur des
chaînes de télé
et cetera et cetera. Ils veulent euh
faire des choses qui aient du sens pour
eux et ils le font en bricolant avec le
RSA, en bricolant avec des prestations
de service qu'il qu'il transforme en
salaire dans des coopératives d'activité
d'emploi, dans des boîtes de portage
salarial. autoentrepreneurs.
Ils sont auto-entrepreneurs, enfin ils
sont dans des statuts de merde.
euh qui fait que lorsqu'on dit "Mais
mais non, nous nous nous avons la
possibilité euh de de de d'affecter à
tous un droit politique au salaire et
quand et quand et quand et quand on ne
le dit pas simplement sous l'angle de
euh vous êtes des êtres de besoins qui
avaient droit à des pouvoirs d'achat
parce que ça c'est méprisant hein, mais
vous êtes des créatifs qui avaient le
droit d'être connus comme tel."
quand on le lit à la propriété de
l'outil pour pas verser une rente au
propriétaire de la plateforme
collaborative chaque fois qu'on fait
bling bling sur leur leur joujou et
cetera là euh là il y a une audience
réelle vraiment je m'en aperçois
donc cette audience vous les trouver
chez les précaires c'est ça
alors je le trouve chez moi je les
qualifie pas de précaire he je les
qualifie de jeunes qualifiés diplômés
qui
euh
sont en train de construire des formes
alternatives de production, ce qui est
le propre de la révolution. La
révolution, c'est changer le mode de
production, c'est produire autrement,
c'est produire une autre valeur selon
d'autres critères et avec d'autres
outils, enfin et cetera et cetera. Et ça
c'est d'autres statuts du travailleur,
d'autres régimes de propriété. Enfin,
c'est ça le le faire la révolution. Euh
ce sont objectivement des
révolutionnaires. Maintenant euh souvent
ils ont été euh
ils sont été maintenus dans l'ignorance
de la tradition, du mouvement syndical,
l'ignorance du marxisme, l'ignorance de
tout ça. Euh ils sont souvent un peu sur
une autre planète du point de vue
idéologique qui les rend vulnérables au
revenu de base par exemple. Parce que
quand vous êtes à 450 balles
conditionnelles du RSA, si un type
arrive en vous disant "Vous avez 800
balles inconditionnel, vous dites banco,
c'est évident.
Donc cette vulnérabilité revenue de
base, c'est une forme de leur fragilité
hein, parce que une fois qu'ils vont
avoir le 800 balles, ils vont encore
plus bosser qu'avec les 450 balles
inconditionnel.
Et donc c'est c'est magique pour le
capital. C'est pour ça que le capital a
absolument besoin de distribuer 800
balles à tout le monde. Non pas non pas
à cause de ce que disait le gaillard de
du début parce qu'il veut maintenir dans
l'ignorance. Enfin ces jeuneslà, ils
sont tous sauf ignorants. Faut arrêter
de dire des conneries. Euh le niveau de
formation de la jeunesse, c'est bien
supérieur à ce qu'il est à ce qu'il
était il y a 50 ans quand ce type-là
faisait ses propres études. Donc la la
la c'est pas c'est pas on n pas affaire
à des à des ignorants, on a affaire à
des gens qui se sont habitués à la
pauvreté parce que depuis 77 depuis les
mesures barres les premiers plans
jeunes, on a habitué la jeunesse à la
pauvreté. Ce qui ce qui est en matière
de de relation familiale d'ailleurs a
complètement changé les choses, hein.
Aujourd'hui, les jeunes, ils aiment
perdument leurs parents. Comment faire
autrement ? obligé. Ils se mettent en
couple beaucoup plus tard. La naissance
du premier enfant, c'est 4 ans plus tard
qu'à 40 ans.
Ça ça a des effets tout à fait
considérables, hein. Cette
c'est une autorégulation.
Bah oui, c'est une forme
d'autorégulation. C'est-à-dire que de
fait ma fois on on s'adapte à la
situation nouvelle pour le pire et pour
le meilleur au sens où on va être
infiniment plus exigeant. Je pense quand
je dis on je parle à c de cette jeunesse
là, elle est un pignant plus exigeante
que que moi dans ma jeunesse sur
l'utilité sociale de ce qu'on fait, sur
le fait de pas produire de la merde pour
le capital. Euh ça c'est
il y a une conscience écologique, il y a
une conscience des solidarités
internationales peut-être aussi qui qui
est qui est plus forte, ça je sais pas
ça, je suis pas très au courant
là-dessus mais
mais il y a oui pour moi un très grand
motif d'espoir. Bien sûr,
on a vu émerger du moins récemment,
c'est un peu plus médiatisé que
d'habitude, le
une nouvelle science qui s'appelle la
collapsologie.
Ça vous parle ?
Euh non, mais j'aurais bien voulu que
quand ils étaient en train de collapser
en 2007, on on laisse tomber les
banquiers et les actionnaires, ça c'est
sûr, ça aurait été très bien qu'on les
laisse collapser ces gens-là.
Malheureusement, il y a eu des états
pour les soutenir, une banque centrale
européenne pour ou une Fed pour créer de
la monnaie à l'appel pour les arroser.
Mais qu'on laisse collapser tout ce
monde là, oui, moi je suis pour. Alors,
la clapsologie c'est étudier en fait les
paramètres de soutenabilité sociétale
qui s'effondrent et qui nous emmènent
inévitablement vers euh un basculement
de paradigme ou un basculement de
société. On va y revenir juste après.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du Glastigle
Act ?
Je connais pas.
Séparation banque de marché, banque
d'affaires.
Ah, c'est ça, c'est ce truc là. Euh,
banque de marché et banque de détail,
pardon. H
ah non je c'est alors redit voir ce que
c'est. Oui.
Séparation banque de marché et banque de
détails.
Banque d'affaires. Non c'est ça où je
Ouais c'est ça. D'accord. Oui. Euh bah
disons que
pour l'a pas fait en 2007
la la mais parce que le capital tient
absolument à la confusion et donc nos
gouvernements sont des gouvernements au
service du capital jusqu'à nouvel ordre.
On n pas on n pas de gouvernement
anticapitaliste en Europe depuis belle
lurette.
Donc on évidemment qu'on a sauvé la mise
de ce temps-là. On a prétendument opéré
un début de séparation des banques
d'affa des banques de marché mais pas du
tout et des banques de détail. Pas du
tout.
Cela dit, encore une fois, c'est pas ma
spécialité donc je ne vous en dirai pas
grand-chose.
Le tout big to fail, je vous pose pas la
question.
Bah le toig to fail si parce que parce
qu'elle est là partir du moment où
Arnaud est en situation de monopole ou
euh le gars des Redites-moi le nom du
gars des des qui qui vole les ports en
Afrique, vous m'avez causé d'Afrique
tout à l'heure
qui volent des ports beaucoup des mecs
qui volent des ports en Afrique.
Ouais mais des ports PORT euh
comment il s'appelle ? Non Boloré. Bon
d'accord.
Euh tous ces t
des sources de ça.
Oui. Bah oui, évidemment. Donc tous ces
tout que tous ces gens-là euh tiennent
le haut du pavé, ce qui est vraiment
répugnant. En plus en plus il se il se
tout leur argent sale, tout ce qu'ils
ont volé, il il lui donnent une belle
couleur
en finançant le 104, en finançant
peut-être Syv, j'en sais rien. En
finançant
encore nous, on est financé que par
notre communauté.
D'accord. euh en finançant euh des trucs
honorables euh en en étant des messes.
Enfin, ce sont des salot absolus tous
ces gens-là dont on va se débarrasser,
bien sûr. Oui. Et
vous allez vous en débarrasser comment ?
On va s'en débarrasser en les
remboursant pas hein. H tout
que vous allez répudier la dette. Ah,
totalement hein. Toutes les dettes de
d'investissement doivent être répudiées.
Euh, on on a commencé à à
réfléchir sur le le non remboursement
des dettes publiques, hein, sur
l'illégitimité de la dette publique.
Quand on prend la dette grecque et
cetera, on dit "Mais si on faisait comme
en Allemagne en 53 et cetera, répudant
la dette publique, ça on a avancé." Mais
sur le fait de répudier la dette privée,
la dette pour financer l'investissement.
Je parle pas d'une dette qu'on contracte
pour acheter une bagnole, je parle d'une
dette qu'on contracte pour financer un
investissement. Ça euh
un petit OP.
Ouais, mais enfin n'importe quoi. Ça
peut être beaucoup plus modeste que ce
truc inutile. La la la
euh est infaisable si j'ai bien compris.
Mais
euh la la
Prenons une une entreprise
qui va contracter, je sais pas quoi moi,
1 2 3 millions d'euros de dette. Euh
d'où vient cet argent ? Soit il est créé
par création monétaire
et
il
va alors qu'il ne vient de rien, il va
mettre le l'endetté en situation de
devoir quelque chose, de devoir
rembourser quelque chose qui n'est rien.
C'est quand même assez incroyable quand
on y réfléchit. une promesse de calories
future.
Ouais, c'est c'est c'est c'est cette
promesse n'a d'effectivité que par le
travail de celui qui va utiliser cet
outil pour produire de la valeur. Et
donc il fait qu'il rembourse, c'est
quand même incroyable.
Euh
avec intérêt,
je conteste d'abord le l'intérêt
évidemment, mais vous voyez actuellement
on a des taux d'intérêt qui peuvent être
même négatifs. Donc c'est pas le taux
d'intérêt qui est le cœur du truc, c'est
le fait même de rembourser hein. Et donc
ce que nous avons inventé là encore, moi
je je ne construis pas un système, je
suis pas un réformateur social du tout,
je suis un historien de ce que nous
avons su construire comme forme de
maîtrise de l'outil de travail.
Un instant T.
Oui, à l'instant qui était 46 qui était
par exemple qui étaient les années
1920 1980 qui sont les années que j'ai
le plus étudié.
On était combien de millions à cette
époque sur Terre ?
Je sais pas, aucune idée.
En France, on était combien ?
En France, on était 40 millions
en 39
et puis on a monté progressivement
à
Pe baisser après 39.
Oui, d'accord. Mais enfin bref, euh on
on a
euh on on on
Mais vos questions démographiques me
paraissent totalement inutiles. Mais
bon, pourquoi pas ? Euh vous c'est
beaucoup importance la démographie chez
vous. C'est Ouais. Ouais. On on a une
lecture un petit peu on fait une veille
sur la démographie. On se pose des
questions comment un système qui donne
des sous avec des cotisations, avec
comme objectif la croissance, on se pos
on se pose des questions. Comment ça se
passe quand la soutenabilité des
facteurs énergétiques, alimentaires,
écologique ne peut plus soutenir cette
fameuse croissance ?
Mais pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi est-ce
que la croissance ça voudrait dire
empreinte écologique ou ça voudrait
croissance démographique ? Est-ce que ça
ça fait une une empreinte écologique ?
La croissance démographique fait de
l'emprunte écologique à coup sûr.
Évidemment. Évidemment.
Ça répond à votre question.
Mais c'est c'est pas euh
nous sommes une société transformant.
Oui.
Oui ou non.
Mais on peut on peut on peut transformer
à des coûts naturels bien inférieurs et
être plus nombreux avec une empreinte
écologique plus faible. Euh dès lors que
une empreinte calorifique aussi plus
faible.
J'y connais rien. Peut-être que non. Je
ne sais pas. Ça c'est des questions qui
me dépassent. pour lesquels j'ai rien à
dire. J'ai des choses à dire
euh en Café du commerce, mais peut-être
pas ici euh sauf si c'est le café du
commerce. Allons-y. Mais enfin ça pas ça
pas ça risque pas être intéressant.
La la
euh
on peut très bien
travailler davantage avec une empreinte
écologique beaucoup plus faible mais
beaucoup plus faible. Le lien qu'on fait
entre travail et donc valeur économique,
puisque la valeur économique c'est la
source, a comme source le travail. Le
lien qu'on fait entre croissance de la
valeur économique et empreinte
écologique, soutenabilité, machin truc
et cetera, euh est un lien euh qui est
un lien très faible. Est-ce
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut le mettre
en parallèle ? Par exemple, à votre
époque, vous rouliez avec une voiture
qui consommait 25 L au 100, on est
d'accord ?
Quand vous avez passé votre permis ?
Peut-être, je l'ai passé assez tard
parce que c'est comme les téléphones,
les bagnoles, ça m'intéresse pas.
Euh quand ma femme en a eu marre de
transporter les gamins tout seul, elle
m'a dit "Passe ton permis, mais j'avais
déjà près de 40 ans, je sais plus."
Elle a attendu quand même que vous ayez
40 ans pour vous faire Bon, passons.
Donc là, à votre époque, il y avait des
voitures qui consomment à fond. Pas
beaucoup de personnes pouvaient
s'acheter des voitures parce que ça
coûtait cher, ça consommait beaucoup.
Bon là en Inde, ils font des voitures
qui consomment très très peu, 2 L, 3 L
100. Donc ça a démocratisé
la voiture, on est d'accord ? Vous vous
nous suivez toujours. Donc si on
commence à faire des empreintes ou des
des consommations plus faibles au niveau
de notre empreinte écologique, notre
empreinte énergétique,
on va avoir beaucoup plus de gens qui
vont vouloir faire la même chose, on est
d'accord ? Et résultat des courses, si
je me suis bien exprimé, l'empreinte
écologique sera toujours supérieure.
Vous me suivez ? Non mais ça c'est
supposé que la bagnole est une bonne
chose qu'elle va se multip
Je parle de la bagnole comme je pourrais
parler d'autres choses hein. Je peux
vous parler de la prothèse de hanche ou
si on si on euh moi par exemple mon mon
empreinte écologique elle est très
faible. Je travaille tout le temps. Mon
empreinte écologique est très faible.
la la
tout dépend ce qu'on appelle travail,
tout dépend ce qu'on appelle valeur
économique. Si on veut par ailleurs,
mettons, faire une agriculture qui soit
respectueuse de la nature, il faut
beaucoup plus de travail, donc produire
beaucoup plus de valeur et et en même
temps, l'empreinte écologique sera
beaucoup plus faible que si on est dans
l'agrobiness
avec des agriculteurs qui sont endettés
à 3 400000 € quand ils ont 30 berge et
qui vont produire du poulet et du porc
que surtout ils n'uront pas leurs
gamins, qui mangeront pas eux-mêmes et
cetera et cetera. Donc la la
c'est c'est le mode de production
capitaliste qui parce qu'il élimine le
travail vivant impose une prédation
considérable sur la nature pour
fabriquer des outils. Et les outils les
plus
dit immatériel dans l'imposture de
l'immatériel du numérique sont les plus
consommateurs de de de minéraux rares de
trucs tout ça pour des choses inutiles.
Ça ça ne sert à rien d'être 4 heur par
jour devant son portable comme ça
aujourd'hui à rien du tout hein.
Question d'internet. Dans quelle banque
mettez-vous votre argent ?
Je mets ma mon argent la banque postale.
Pourquoi ?
Euh parce que c'est une c'est une banque
publique.
Pas
pas pas parce que vous avez étudié son
taux d'endettement, son effet de levier
sur les marchés. Pas du tout.
Ah non, pas du tout. Non non non non.
Ben pourquoi faire ? Moi je je je
n'ai aucune épargne hein. Aucune.
Zéro
zéro.
Vous êtes propriétaire de votre logement
?
Je suis propriétaire de mon logement. Je
n'ai pas de de titre, je n'ai pas de
d'assurance vie, j'ai pas de machin, je
n'ai absolument rien de tout ça. Euh et
j'ai avec ma femme des comptes joints
joints.
Euh
jour au niveau de vos impôts.
Mes impôts mes impôts se montent à
euh
Attendez voir l'impôt sur leur venu. Je
crois qu'on était à 16000 € par mois,
par an l'an dernier, je ne sais plus. un
truc dans ce goûtl. Bon, des fois des
fois je me trompe d'une année sur
l'autre à manière.
Question d'Internet, comment
estimez-vous le niveau de salaire de
ceux dont le travail n'est pas forcément
lié à une qualification des artistes,
des inventeurs, des entrepreneurs ? Ben
qu'il faut les qualifier parce que sinon
c'est une logique de marché. On va avoir
des divas et puis des gens qui crèvent
de faim euh autour des divas. Donc je
pense qu'il faut au contraire multiplier
la logique de qualification des
personnes. Mais qualifier un artiste
c'est pas comme qualifier un prof ou
qualifier un maçon. C'est c'est
forcément différent. Les épreuves sont
différentes, le type d'attendu est
différent. Bien sûr, il faut adapter les
épreuves de qualification au type de de
valeur d'usage qui est produite, au type
de compétences qui sont qui sont
mobilisées et cetera. Bien sûr.
Comment on les qualifie ?
Alors, comment on qualifie ? Bah ça
qui juge ? Alors, on sait faire tout ça
parce qu'encore une fois, moi, je suis
un historien d'un processus qui s'est
construit sur un siècle avec des gens
qui sont mobilisés, qui ont laissé euh
euh beaucoup de leur vie euh dans la
construction du salaire à la
qualification, du droit de salaire et
cetera. Et euh on on
on a des des équipes syndicales qui sont
parfaitement au courant de la façon dont
on qualifie un poste de travail, hein,
selon quel critère on va attribuer un
certain niveau de qualification à poste
de travail. Et bien transposons cela à
la qualification de personne, hein. Ce
qu'il faut maintenant, c'est passer
d'une qualification du poste à une
qualification de personne. Alors, les
juris, ben il faut pas que ce soit des
gens qui ont bossé avec parce que sinon
euh il va y avoir du copinage, du bras
de cuissage, du machin, du truc. Il faut
qu'il y ait une forme d'anonymat euh par
exemple. Bon, ça c'est une règle de base
très simple qui est d'ailleurs
relativement appliqué dans la fonction
publique d'état par exemple hein. Les
juris c'est pas c'est pas les gens avec
qui on a bossé évidemment. Il y a pas de
droit de cuissage dans la fonction
publique.
Non, mais je veux dire en rajoutant pas
par des raisons institutionnelles de le
faire, hein. Euh que la domination
masculine existe là comme ailleurs, ça
c'est pas c'est évident, mais
nouvelle forme d'école, vous avez des
idées ? Oui, bien sûr, hein. Si si nous
souhaitons que euh
chacun euh à 18 ans soit euh
attributaire de trois droits nouveaux,
hein. Premièrement, un droit
à la qualification et on attribue à tout
le monde, quel que soit son passé
scolaire, quel que soit son handicap, à
18 ans ou enfin à l'âge de la majorité
politique, pensez à 18 ans chez nous, on
on on attribue le premier niveau de
qualification et les 1500 balles qui
vont avec à vie. Bon euh et ce droit-là,
c'est pas un droit encore une fois à un
revenu de base, c'est un droit à un
salaire, c'est-à-dire à une carrière
salariale qui pourra aller jusqu'à 6000
€
tant que délibérément nous aurons choisi
cela. on peut délibérer
que ce soit de 1 à 3 ou de 1 à 2, enfin
peu importe l'hiérarchie des salaires,
ça c'est une question qui relève de la
démocratie, du combat du conflit
démocratique. Euh deuxème droit à 18
ans, le droit d'être propriétaire
d'usage de l'outil qu'on utilisera. On
en est propriétaire d'usage,
on en est pas propriétaire
patrimonial, hein.
Euh l'utilisateur de l'outil, il en est
propriétaire d'usage. Un outil, c'est à
la fois quelque chose qui sert, hein. Je
vois votre studio live là 16. Bon, c'est
quelque chose qui sert. Euh et puis
c'est un patrimoine, ça vaut quelque
chose. Bon, distinguons bien la
propriété d'usage et la propriété
patrimoniale. L'outil de travail doit
être la propriété d'usage de ceux qui
l'utilisent. C'està-dire c'est eux qui
décident
de ce qu'ils font avec cet outil, où est
cet outil, qui travaille dessus et
cetera et cetera. Ça c'est absolument
décisif. La propriété patrimoniale, il
faut pas que ce soit un truc lucratif,
sinon il y aura pas de propriété
d'usage, hein. Si c'est si c'est
lucratif,
euh ceux qui tirent euh profit du
travail de ceux qui utilisent le TI,
d'accord, ils vont leur imposer bien sûr
ce qu'ils ont à faire. Donc, il y aura
pas de propriété d'usage s'il y a
propriété lucrative patrimoniale. Donc,
il s'agit de mettre en place une
propriété patrimoniale non lucrative par
des collectivités publiques. Vous avez
le mot communauté à la bouche, vous
c'est votre truc. Bon ben voilà, vous
avez une communauté qui est
propriétaire, je l'espère, patrimoniale,
non lucrative de ce studio Live 16 et
vous en êtes, je l'espère, propriétaire
d'usage. Bon, ça c'est bien, ça ça
marche, c'est super, c'est comme ça
qu'il faut qu'on fonctionne.
Et euh encore une fois, c'est pas
un truc que je vais chercher sur la Lune
ou en Alaska ou je sais pas quoi. C'est
ce que nous avons construit. C'est
exportable au Bangladesh.
Certainement. Tout tout tout pays est en
capacité mais avec des des des histoires
propres, des institutions propres. Donc
moi de ne je peux vous dire que c'est
exportable
c'est transposable en Allemagne, en
Autriche,
enfin dans des pays
dont dont je sais que l'histoire est
proche.
On hériterait c'est exportable.
J'en sais rien et et très franchement
c'est des questions que je me pose pas
parce que j'ai appris à me poser des
questions sur lesquelles j'ai quelques
éléments de réponse. Pour le reste, je
m'en remets à des spécialistes.
Si si s'il y a plus d'emploi, qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Mais pourquoi il y aurait
plus d'emploi ? Enfin,
par exemple,
un exemple un exemple, on dit on arrête
les voitures.
Ben, on arrête les voitures, ça veut
dire qu'on multiplie
les des des transports en commun de
faible taille. euh sur rail ou sur eau
ou
on arrête le nucléaire. Tout tous ceux
qui travaillent dans le nucléaire, on
leur fait casser les cailloux.
Non, pas du tout. Ceux qui travaillent
dans le nucléaire ont une énorme
qualification professionnelle. Ce sont
des gens pour lesquels il faut qu'il y
ait une transposition de leur
qualification dans d'autres champs. Je
faisais allusion moi c'est à ces
militant CGT de Talè qui se battent pour
pour que toutes leurs compétences soit
voué à autre chose qu'à vendre des armes
pour entretenir les guerres sur
l'ensemble des continents. Et c'est bien
des gens qui qui qui réfléchissent sur
la transposition de de qualification
très élevée sur d'autres objets. Tout ça
tout simple. Mais pour que ça puisse se
faire, pour que ces transitions puissent
se faire, il faut pas que leur salaire
soit lié à leur poste. Parce que si leur
salaire est lié à leur poste, ils vont
défendre leur poste. Et moi, c'est pas
moi qui les qui irit leur faire la
morale. Que que des salariés de Fenahim
défendent leur boulot, moi je n'irai pas
leur faire la morale. En revanche, je
milite pour que ce ne soit plus leur
poste à Fenheim qui soit le support de
leur salaire, mais eux. Dans ce cas-là,
ils accepteront évidemment une mutation
complète de l'usine ou et cetera parce
que ce n'est pas leur poste de travail
qui est le support de leurs droits.
C'est ça la nouveauté. Je voulais
insister tout à l'heure
sur le fait que le la propriété
patrimoniale non lucrative qui rend
possible une propriété d'usage par les
travailleurs, c'est ce que nous avons
fait à grande échelle pour la production
de santé. Nous avons construit
l'appareil de santé dans les années 60.
C'était un mourroir avant l'hôpital,
mourroir complet. On a construit
l'appareil de santé dans les années 60
avec un investissement tout à fait
considérable sans faire appel
majoritairement au marché des capitaux.
On a augmenté le taux de cotisation
maladie. L'assurance maladie a pu
subventionner
les hôpitaux. Les hôpitaux n'ont pas eu
à rembourser. Les soignants, ils ont
soigné, ils ont pas remboursé. Ils ont
pas travaillé pour rembourser, ils ont
travaillé pour soigner. et ils ont été
du coup propriétaires d'usage de cet
outil qui était la propriété de la
sécurité sociale. Voilà, ce modèle là,
il faut l'étendre à toute la production.
Elle peut être produite avec un outil
qui est la propriété de collectivité
publique et une propriété d'usage par
les travailleurs eux-mêmes.
Est-ce que vous connaissez la
proposition d'Ivan sur une société sans
école ? Oui, je je je suis de l'âge des
lecteurs de Ils quand il écrivait euh
dans les à la fin des années 60. C'est
euh ces ces ces travaux. Euh
euh je cherche l'autre qui est toujours
lié à lui. Mince. Bref. aussi
et et donc euh
je je moi je suis encore une fois pour
une société euh dans laquelle l'école
soit une éducation à la responsabilité à
la coresponsabilité
en matière de production de la valeur
économique et donc que ce soit une école
sans note, une école sans filière avec
une obligation de résultat du coup pour
les enseignants parce que les filières
c'est ce qui permet de d'attribuer aux
élèves eux-mêmes l'échec
Donc évidemment supprimer les filières,
supprimer les notes et faire une
éducation qui soit une éducation à la à
la coresponsabilité, hein. Encore une
fois, le capitalisme il nous il nous nie
comme responsable en permanence et donc
c'est cette éducation à la
coresponsabilité qui doit être le cœur
de l'école.
Si on narrive pas à faire votre
changement de paradigme, il va se passer
quoi ? C'est quoi votre vision du futur
?
Ah ben j'ai pas de j'ai pas de plan B.
Donc
vous avez bien vécu hein. Non.
Ah j'ai j'ai un j'ai un vécu qui est une
chance. C'est pour ça que je préconise
de la généraliser. Moi, j'ai eu 40 ans
de salaire à vie dans l'autogestion avec
une propriété d'usage total de mon outil
qui est une propriété non lucrative du
point de vue patrimonial. J'ai fait ce
que j'ai voulu, non pas ce que j'ai
voulu au sens au sens libertarien du
terme, ça c'est de la connerie hein.
J'ai j'ai pu en permanence délibérer
avec les collègues.
J'ai pu me soumettre au au verdict des
étudiants.
Le nombre de quelqu'un dans un nombre
d'étudiant un amphi, c'est un sacré
verdict. Donc l'ampi est plein ou il est
vide et cetera. J'ai dû me soumettre en
permanence au verdict de mes collègues.
Quand je faisais une proposition de
communication à congrès, on me disait
oui non, une proposition d'ouvrage ?
Oui, non, une proposition de ceci, cela
de d'un programme de recherche ? Bah
non, oui, non. Euh j'ai été évalué en
permanence euh
mais avec un salaire attaché à ma
personne, avec un outil dont j'étais
propriétaire d'usage et ça pendant 40
ans, c'est le pied. Je vous assure.
Tu es un vrai anard toi.
Oui, je suis anart bien sûr. Oui.
L'anarchie du 21e siècle, elle en est où
?
Euh j'y je connais rien parce que moi je
suis au parti communiste. Donc ma ma
famille politique n'est parfait hein.
Euh ma famille politique euh ne se
revendique pas de l'anarchie au sens où
euh un certain nombre de de fédération
anarchiste, alternative liberté et ce de
mouvement se revendique de l'anarchie
mais il se revendique aussi du
communisme hein euh anarchie communisme
tout ça c'est des termes qui sont assez
assez frères même s'ils sont parfois en
conflit
sont toujours frères sur les fiches S
par exemple. Oui, sans doute. Oui. Oui.
Mais je je ne
pas été jusqu'ici victime de trac
policier, mais je je dois dire que la
que le j'ai appris de de Marx, j'ai
appris de la de la de la lecture du
capital comme une contradiction
à l'œuvre. euh un
[Musique]
une
revendication de de de
faire sujet hein macroéconomique euh et
la conviction de la capacité pour les
travailleurs d'être des sujets
macroéconomiques
en mesure de d'émanciper le travail du
carcan capitaliste. Tout comme la
bourgeoisie a jou un rôle
révolutionnaire au 14e 15e 16e siècle,
elle elle subvertit les institutions de
la féodalité
et elle institue un mode de production
infiniment supérieur. On est maintenant
à une autre étape où il faut en finir
avec le mode de production capitaliste.
Pour un mode de production communiste,
ça et c'est et c'est à ça que je
travaille à ma façon.
Vous voyez un parti politique, une
initiative qui pourrait faciliter ces
choses-là ?
Bah moi, je suis donc
Macron, comme vous l'avez dit,
j'ai adhéré en j'ai adhéré en 69 au
Parti communiste.
Je l'ai quitté à une période où vraiment
ça a été la grande déconfiture
idéologique
organisationnelle. Je suis revenu. Euh
en même temps, c'est un parti qui est en
très très grande difficulté. Euh c'est
ma famille politique que je connais
beaucoup de militants. Tout à fait
remarquable. Il y a une longue histoire.
Il y a maintenant quand même depuis 1920
et même avant parce que c'est des ceux
qui ont fait le particul 1920, ils
venaient de la SFIO, ils ont construit
la CGT en 95, enfin à Lim 95. Là, on a
on a 120 130 ans de de d'un trésor
militant moi vraiment que je ne retrouve
pas dans d'autres traditions, mais que
je connais moins hein, je connais moins
les traditions proprement anarchistes ou
trosquistes ou autres ou socialistes.
Bon
euh mais en même temps, il faut bien
constater que ce trésor là pour le
moment, il est dans un dans un vase
d'argile.
Euh
je je constate parce que je suis aussi
très invité par des groupes d'appui de
France insoumise et autres qu'il y a à
France insoumise une forme de dynamique
que je trouve pas actuellement au Parti
communiste qui est un parti plus
vieillissant et cetera.
Euh
bah très bien. Euh
le je je ne
je constate aussi que beaucoup de gens
qui sont actuellement hors parti
politique encore une fois sont sur des
positions objectivement révolutionnaires
d'un point de vue politique parce que
ils veulent produire veulent produire
autrement. Et ça pour moi c'est c'est
une position révolutionnaire.
Euh tout ça n'a pas d'expression
politique
construite qui permettent de
Il faut passer par là.
Est-ce que vous votez encore ?
Oui oui oui oui. Bah oui. Moi j'ai
Vous avez voté quoi aux dernières
élections ? Emmanuel Macron ?
J'ai Ah non au second tour j'ai j'ai été
voté parce que je vais voter mais j'ai
mis je sais pas quoi une une annerie
dans leur je sais pas quoi. Enfin j'ai
j'ai voté nul blanc je ne sais plus
exactement. Je n'ai évidemment pas voté.
J'ai pas choisi entre la peste et le
coléra.
Vous êtes pour le vote blanc ou pour le
vote nul ?
Je suis moi pour le boycotte de
l'élection présidentiel. Je pense que
cette élection, c'est l'élection Pierc
par excellence qui a détruit notre vie
démocratique, qui en fait qui la résume
un concours de beauté caquenal
euh qui qui
accentue un penchant trop fort déjà dans
notre pays pour le besoin d'un chef.
Enfin tout ça tout ça est ou d'une chef
tê mais enfin toujours pareil quoi.
C'est c'est tout ça est est absolument
dramatique. Et s'agissant de mon parti
le Parti communiste, il est clair que
c'est la élection présidentielle qui a
été qui a été l'origine de son déclin.
Donc je suis pour un travail de
de qu'on fasse la fête devant les
bureaux de vote à chaque présidentiel et
qu'on et qu'on empêche l'élection de se
tenir. C'est ça mon ma proposition.
S'agissant des présidentiels. Alors sur
les autres les autres élections. Non, je
suis pour les élections. Il faut il faut
évidemment mais il faut se débarrasser
de l'extra présidentiel qui est une
saloperie. Si je vous dis quand les les
mangeoires sont pleines, les veaux sont
dociles.
Bah non, moi j'attends pas j'attends
pas. Moi maoire est pleine, je suis pas
docile.
Euh et puis et puis les vaaux, je laisse
ça à votre interlocuteur de départ là,
les 85 % de genre
c'est non non non, personne n'est un
vaau pour moi. C'est c'est inadmissible
même de penser comme ça. Si je vous dis
quand il
je je connais tellement de gens
remarquables qui passent pour des
Regardez, j'étais j'étais chez des
militants communistes parce que beaucoup
de militants communistes accueillent
chez eux des migrants évidemment euh
à Nice à la mi-janvier chez deux deux
vieilles dames, deux jeunes migrants
guinéens,
l'un de 21 ans, l'autre de 26 ans, un
qui était linguiste, l'autre qui était
paysan. Bon, de avoir deux profils très
différents. 1 an et demi de galère, il
se ils se connaissaient pas évidemment,
ils sont connus en Italie. Un an et demi
de galère mais effroyable peut arriver.
Mais ce sont des héros ces gens-là.
C'est c'est nous sommes entourés de
héros en permanence. Donc c'est moi
c'est moi je suis à l'école de héros
tout le temps. C'est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs mon bonheur de vivre.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les migrants ?
Ben, les migrants, on peut les
accueillir par euh par million. Nous
sommes un pays vide euh
qui
peut évidemment euh accueillir des
quantités de migrants. Euh c'est c'est
une honte.
Si vous voulez, pour accueillir des
migrants et nous pouvons le faire de
manière considérable, il faut que nous
sortions du capitalisme parce que le
capitalisme, encore une fois, il élimine
le travail vivant et donc il tend à
réduire en permanence l'espace du
travail, hein, au point que certains
croient qu'il y aura de moins en moins
d'emploi et cetera, comme si la logique
capitaliste était inéluctable. Mais moi
ce que je remarque et je suis payé euh
d'une exprime cela, c'est que on a
étendu le champ du travail. Moi je je
travaille en ce moment. C'est-à-dire que
le le travail c'est pas simplement
mettre en valeur du capital. Ça c'est ce
que dit la bourgeoisie. Le travail que
ceux qui mettent en valeur du capital,
les autres il dépensent.
Euh mais ce que fait le mouvement
ouvrier quand il se construit comme
mouvement révolutionnaire, il est le
champ du travail. Il verse du salaire
aux parents. La loi crois 46, c'est du
salaire pour les parents. C'est pas une
allocation de solidarité financée par la
CSG. Ça c'est ce que FR Rocard, ce que
fait Croisa, ministre communiste du
travail qui crée le régime général de
sécurité sociale. Les parents ont droit
à 225 he pour deux gamins de l'ouvrier
spécialisé de la métallurgie. C'estàd
qu'ils sont considérés comme plus
productifs que les métallurgistes. On
étend le champ du travail, on sort le
travail de son carquant capitaliste. Et
du coup, si on étend le champ du
travail, mais on peut accueillir
infiniment plus de travailleurs. Si on
veut une agriculture bio, il faut
infiniment plus de travail vivant que
pour l'agriculture FNSA.
Ça va, ça se défend encore, hein. C'est
bien, c'est bien.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait euh si euh
les on va dire si on traverse un un
événement exotique qui excite
les plus radicaux d'entre nous, ceux qui
ont une conception de l'identité
française différente de la vôtre, on
leur fait comprendre comment.
C'est moi je passe pas mon temps à à
faire le compte des malheurs possibles.
C'est c'est une limite he je ne Mais
est-ce que vous essayez de dialoguer
avec les gens qui n'ont pas le même
point de vue que vous ?
À chaque fois que j'en ai la
possibilité, je le fais évidemment. Ça
bien sûr hein, j'en ai pas souvent la
possibilité àad, je dois le dire parce
que je suis très peu invité euh
par des gens qui me serait vraiment
hostile. Ça va être le cas euh
à Science Po à Lyon la semaine prochaine
ou dans 15 jours, je ne sais plus.
Il y a une une association étudiante de
gauche, disons, une association
étudiante qui s'appelle je sais plus
quoi Syn Liberal, enfin truc de droite
qui euh qui me font venir avec un
un mec qui est un un libertarien.
Aujourd'hui, on voulait vous faire venir
avec Charles Gave ou Pierre Sabatier,
mais manque de peau, ils étaient pas
libres,
mais je les connais pas. Euh et et donc
là, il va y avoir une confrontation, ça
c'est sûr, mais c'est pas si fréquent
que ça finalement, hein, la
confrontation. Mais en tous les cas, moi
mon problème c'est pas comment répondre
à des événements euh
qui nous tomberaient sur la gueule.
C'est c'est
parce que je suis badoué pour ça. C'est
c'est comment créer
un oui he comme je disais un oui
populaire
un sentiment de dignité collective qui
fait qu'on a envie de produire
autrement, qu'on a envie d'être maître
de notre production, qu'on a envie qu'on
a un sens de notre capacité, notre
responsabilité. Enfin, c'est ça que
j'essaie de construire moi. C'est ça qui
m'intéresse.
On arrive à la dernière partie de notre
interview. Notre dernière question qui
n'est pas vraiment une question, c'est
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, une bouteille à la mer sur
les sur les réseaux, quelque chose
d'impérissable.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez à leur dire aux
jeunes ?
Bah, j'ai à dire ce que j'ai déjà dit,
c'est-à-dire mon admiration pour tous
ceux qui sont dans une forme de
dissidence.
Il y a des connards chez les jeunes.
Il y a des macronistes qui attendent que
le Brexit fasse que la que la place
financière de Paris devienne pas vous
permettre de vous laisser dire ça.
D'accord. D'accord. D'accord.
On respecte tout le monde ici. D'accord.
Très bien. Très bien. Très bien.
Compris les gens de gauche, de droite.
D'accord. D'accord. D'accord. J'ai dit
pourtant du mal de gens m'avez pas
interrompu mais
parce que bon mais
on est poli.
D'accord.
Avec les vieux.
D'accord. le
disons que euh
mon admiration
euh
pour une forme de de d'authenticité,
c'est-à-dire que
dans dans euh les militants que je
connais, euh
moi j'ai connu par exemple dans des
collègues beaucoup de gens qui étaient
de gauche vraiment qui était des
scientifiques qui faisaient une critique
du capitalisme enfin et cetera et cetera
et cetera, mais qui sur le point
professionnel était vraiment à droite.
Enfin, il y avait une forme de de de
d'incohérence
entre
les positions, disons intellectuelles et
et la vie. Chez tous ces jeunes là, je
constate au contraire une forme de
cohérence que pour lequel je suis très
admiratif. Alors, ce que j'ai envie de
le dire ensuite, c'est euh
nous avons un siècle et demi de
mouvements populaires, de mouvements
ouvriers
autour de la CGT, autour du Parti
communiste pour prendre ces deux
institutions emblématiques, hein,
fossilisé. Euh
c'est c'est vous voyez là, je vous
prends en flagrant délit de dire du mal
euh de chacun son tour
d'institution alors que vous prétendez
ne pas en dire ou ne pas accepter qu'il
y en a dit.
C'est un état de fait. Euh dans ce
cas-là, c'est un état de fait qu'une
partie de la jeunesse est conne et et et
attendre Macron
le salut des start-ups.
la
euh
je je je dis à tous ces jeunes qui euh
qui sont souvent dans l'ignorance de
cette tradition, mais cette tradition
elle est porteuse de merveille parce que
elle a sucong des institutions macro, le
statut de la fonction publique, la SNCF,
ça c'est des conquêtes absolument
considérables
euh que la classe dirigeante a toujours
contesté, qu'elle est aujourd'hui en
mesure peut-être même de faire passer à
la trappe tellement nous sommes dans le
recul organisationnel
du côté du mouvement ouvrier.
Il faut absolument que nous accrochions
nos wagons, les toute cette jeunesse de
l'alternative et tous les les militants
cégu communistes, on va dire
de la
aujourd'hui sur la défensive. Il faut il
faut vraiment parce que on va pas sortir
du capitalisme par une addition
de de chaîn Syerview. C'est pas
possible. Il faut qu'il y ait en
permanence de l'alternative ici et
maintenant. Mais il faut aussi qu'il y
ait une capacité de fédérer, de faire du
macro, de sorte que ce soit pas
uniquement par des recherche de dons
communautair mais par une institution de
collecte de de cotisation que le
financement comme là.
Non non mais encore une fois,
je je suis pas là à faire l'alcent qui
que ce soit. Je je suis là à dire euh il
faut marcher sur les deux pieds de
l'alternative ici et maintenant et de la
construction de de d'institutions macro
qui permettent à cette alternative de
n'être pas récupérable. Je sais pas
quoi. Prenons la ruche qui dit oui au
départ c'est très bien. Puis à
l'arrivée, c'est Xavier Nil qui
a fait une saloperie avec un truc
intéressant. Donc soit récupéré soit
marginal. Alors à la niche, bon des gens
à la niche, ça n'a jamais dérangé le
capital. Euh
sortir de cette alternative là, c'est
possible. Le mouvement ouvrier était
capable de faire du de l'alternative
macro et c'est ça qu'il faut faire
ensemble.
Euh je vais gratter encore un petit peu.
On a une dernière question qui est
d'ailleurs, je te voyais déjà prêt à
couper. Comment vous distinguez le bon
et le mauvais travail ? Ça c'est une
question qu'on s'est pas posée. C'est
quoi le bon travail ? Alors le bah pour
moi le bon travail c'est un travail qui
qui fait sens hein d'un point de vue
anthropologique,
d'un point de vue territorial, d'un
point de vue écologique pour prendre
trois grandes dimensions à mon avis
centrale. D'un point de vue
anthropologique, c'est-à-dire qu' encore
une fois un travail qui euh qui qui qui
nous qui nous confirme dans notre
humanité
d'un point de vue territorial, quelque
chose qui ne crée pas des déserts autour
de métropole. qui sont en train de
désertifier complètement leur zone de
chalise
de point de vue écologique, ça c'est
évident et ça tout le monde va être vite
d'accord
essence mais je voudrais insister sur la
dimension anthropologique du travail
parce que elle est
elle est beaucoup trop sous-estimée
aujourd'hui.
D'ailleurs, le capital qui nous qui qui
ne nous laisse pas décider au travail,
il nous il nous occupe avec nos 4 heures
par jour à dire je suis dans le train,
comment ça va à aller voir des je sais
pas quoi, aller regarder où on est où on
est l'info aujourd'hui. On continue
enfin à se à se distraire,
s'hypnotiser.
Oui. s' hypnotisé dans l'in
témoigne que l'on vit on s'informe
beaucoup mieux en écoutant pas la radio,
en ayant pas la télé et en ayant pas de
téléphone. C'est infiniment supérieur.
Bernard Friot, merci.
Merci beaucoup à vous. Couper.
[Musique]